hey David isn't Donald Trump insulting
people in his base when he is calling
his opponents short fat weak
ugly whatever else the case may be isn't
there a political risk to this so yeah I
mean Donald Trump's insults to others
not just other candidates but people in
general gold star families all sorts of
different people of course there are
people in Donald Trump's base who should
feel equally insulted by Donald Trump's
attacks but they don't care and the tea
party in 2010 is a perfect example
Donald Trump has insulted all sorts of
different people Native Americans
through calling Elizabeth Warren
Pocahontas short people with his mini
Mike Bloomberg attacks low IQ is a very
popular thing that Donald Trump says
despite saying he loves the uneducated
his attack on people his attacks on
people as low IQ disproportionately
people of color by the way of course
should be seen as an attack on other
people as well the the sort of [ __ ]
attacks which include calling people
weak lightweight little crying all of
that stuff
calling sometimes Trump insults others
as racist and anti-semitic this one's
extra funny because there are so many
people in Trump's base who are racist
and anti-semitic fake and dishonest and
that one's probably safe I don't know
that too many people would take that
personally able to say I'm not fake or
dishonest but yes a lot of the insults
Donald Trump uses apply to people in his
base think though of the tea party back
in 2010 the tea party voted against
their personal economic best interests
in order to vote in favor of what they
perceived to be the orthodoxy or the
dogma of their group best interests and
Jonathan height eye outlines this very
well in his books where he says you know
you see a tea party he doesn't say in
these terms I think he wrote the book
two years before the tea party I think
or a couple years after but forget about
his example specifically but what he is
saying as applied to the tea party would
be you see a tea party person and they
are not they're not rich they are not
going to be rich they would benefit from
policies of somebody like Bernie Sanders
and yet they vote for Republicans
like at the time you know it was whether
it was Mitt Romney or Paul Ryan or
whoever people whose economic policy
will not benefit them this seems like
they're voting against their own best
interests they are voting against their
own personal best interest but they are
voting in favor of what their group or
tribe has said is their orthodoxy or is
best for the country that's what you
have to understand so when it when you
hear well Donald Trump is making fun of
overweight people and uneducated people
and Native Americans and all of these
other things and and many of the people
in his base have these characteristics
it is not at all a stretch for someone
to say well that voting for Trump is
still in the best interests of my group
even if he seems to be attacking me
personally and very clearly it doesn't
seem to be a big liability for Donald
Trump because the insults continue to
come and as much as they might apply to
people in his own base it is not
affecting his approval rating with the
Republican Party almost at all so sure
sir Trump insults people in his in his
base all the time doesn't seem to be
having any negative effect on him